jean louis aubert bonsoir ça s'est
vraiment passé comme elle a été la
dernière à en nier cela vient
quel bilan tu fais de la journée au
bahreïn cola le s'est terminée le signal
au moins deux mois de décembre je dois
faire un bilan
aiful tu fasses un bilan pour ce que
c'est et ça c'est une bonne seconde et
90 c'était une bonne journaliste et
vierne et puis pour nous c'était un re
départ on a traversé toute la france en
jouant comme ça je sais pas précis mais
dylan est il plus éclatée par exemple
oui ce que c'était le mieux ou est ce
que dans les filiales et bien pas un bon
la cigale c'est bien parce que paris ça
reste toujours surtout en fin de tournée
quoi ça reste pas une consécration mais
on donne tout ce qu'on a appris au cours
des concerts j'ai bien aimé la belgique
aussi que sa première fois de ma vie que
jamais elle est partout de télé ou un
téléphone en amérique vous
en australie vous n'êtes pas les films
en gt japon ouais c'est quand vous êtes
allé quand vous êtes au japon vous y
allez en australie ouais mais finalement
est-ce qu'ils étaient claque de plus
qu'une avancée
donc j'aime bien en belgique parce que
j'ai remarqué pour la première fois de
ma vie ça va ne pas parler avant qu'ils
étaient en avance sur nous parce qu'il
était vraiment européen je regrette pas
le sabordage de téléphone quoi si
c'était à refaire je referais la même
chose je sais pas si moh sabordage c'est
un peu un sondage
comment s est de couler un bateau qui va
bien on a coulé un bateau qui avait des
trous donc
si jamais ça mais ne savait pas encore
arrivé de regretter ça m'est arrivé de
regretter que les gens redresse
mais comprendre qu'on n'est pas
on n'avait pas envie de terminer quelque
chose qu'ils y aillent qui avait
toujours été bien pour nous que ça
devienne une banalité comme il y en a
plein tu es revoit les autres taurine
par exemple tu l'as à tuléar bois tu
appelles tu commences à ce label par non
vous n'y a pas de nouvelles non pas son
nom
mais on se croise quand même qu'est-ce
vous vous dire pendant voyez comme ça
l'école dans lesquelles on les récupère
contraire ça t'embête un peu ça quand
même
non parce que dans 4 r les choses
superficielles samarie selon le
quotidien d'avoir des chaussures genre
de scène par yves armes sont les gens
comment et leur moral et ça on va pas
quand on t'envoie quelques instants
comme ça et qu'on a vécu 15 ans ensemble
on va pas dire de la bague de
travailleurs des choses très important
les poussines
bertignac il a remué là
produit pas plus de moi je ne sais trop
points puis les variations faire des
chez lui rens tu penses que j'opère
jouer ensemble que lui certains beatles
ont joué ensemble à des moments une
certain beatles damon romaine et tu fais
quoi en ce moment la cocotte les vitres
c'est quoi le nez pointu je ne sais pas
s'il en est avec des morts un jour c'est
pas moi
bref tu fais quoi en ce moment là je me
suis installé dans une usine qui
s'appelle l' usine studio on allait sur
dans une pétition avec des machines et
des copains et on fait tourner des trucs
on s'amuse en son nom c'est la musique
tous les jours et en fait plus on est
censé travailler vrai pour les gens du
rpt qui nous regardent
professionnellement on leur dit qu'on
travaille en fait cet art sarrio n'est
plus j'écoute points en jeu commentait
la musique
j'écoute toujours le double pince un
concert de kyo à orange aussi que j'ai
eu
par des biens détournés donc j'ai tiré
de la console et c'est super jadis de
table à mouthanna besta pour les 20e
anniversaire en s'associant la route
quand j'écoute toujours ça
l'album 10 qui pulse est bien lequel ce
dernier 1
presque tout j'aime bien les chansons du
guip l'idiot le sport live j'aime bien
ils sont tous adorent ce qu'il écrit
j'écoute aussi des prêts ce mode de
dernier c'est lassant son album et
j'aime bien quand même
j'aime bien les paroles c'est très bien
ça t'a laissé coi téléphone à part un
nom
cette année c'est de l'argent à la
banque non pas l'avant et dans un coffre
non non dans ton jardin jeanne acheté ma
maison
elle est bien ta maison ouais elle est
où ben a voulu elle est grande
moi c'est une usine aussi partiellement
ses pastels design élancé la maison
urbaine à grands pas parce qu'on appelle
ça des lofts
et en fait ça nous a laissé sa chacun à
peu près vont pas venir un énorme tas
d'argent fait combien pour les gens
sachent que ça peut rapporter d'avoir
pété les plombs après ils vont devenir
tous les ans trente mille ans ancien on
dit mais ça va et puis de quoi de quoi
faire un nouveau groupe par sa chance en
le faisant